I'm in the coffee room where element 109
meitnerium was named in here imagine
eight twenty people sitting around
arguing what we can pull this new
element writing the names on the
blackboard they rubbed it off but there
they had the whole choice of what the
elements were called
like many other of these very heavy
elements Meitner room is made by taking
a nucleus of a heavy element and banging
into it a lighter element in the case of
this one you have led with atomic number
82 and bang into it
cobalt or alternatively you can have
bismuth which has atomic number 83 and
bang in iron which has atomic number 1
less than cobalt so you have two
different ways of making the same
element I was just told by Sigurd
Hoffmann one of the discoverers they
chose the name meitnerium because Lisa
Meitner who was the co-discoverer of
fission of atoms never got the nobel
prize her collaborator Otto Hahn got the
Nobel Prize she didn't
now she's got an element named after her
and he hasn't so her name will live
longer than his I think be really
exciting to choose the name of an
element well professor you're sitting
next to a man who does get to name
elements this is your one chance to tell
him who you think he should call any
future elements that he might get to
have a say let's see what you're gonna
suggest to him I think I still think
that it would be nice to to honor Max
Planck and I also think that Planck iam
is a nice name it rolls off the tongue
what do you say Planck iam we give that
one we keep pay that one in more in
forest next time you have to name an
element I think now Planck M we can
write in bold letters because he already
was on our list okay there you go
thank you might be in the ready mix now
you happy yes Lisa might know was the
first woman ever to get a PhD a
doctorate in physics in Austria and then
she moved to Berlin during the first
world war she worked on a mobile x-ray
unit for x-ray wounded soldiers and then
she
worked in Berlin with Max Planck and
there's a very nice story that
Rutherford sent radioactive samples to
them by post from Cambridge and she
could tell when a parcel was coming from
Cambridge before looking at it well the
postman was still holding it because her
Geiger counter started detecting
radioactivity coming out of the parcel
people weren't quite so careful when
they sent radioactive samples in those
days as they are now